[Musique]
on est dans le parc la fontaine près
d'une école que tu connais bien mon
primaire s'est déroulée justice y avait
une enseignante qui était content pour
toi puis la beauté de la chose c'est
quand vous allez vous retrouver oh mon
dieu
[Rires]
ça fait tellement longtemps ils ont très
bien petit souvenait de moi
17 ans
equal ou non les remixes c'était une
certain que systématiquement au moins
une fois par mois quand j'écoute
épicerie je me demande je
me posais toujours j'ai toujours pensé à
toi aussi là chaque fois que j'écoute et
l'épicerie les conversations qu'on avait
dans la cour d'école le lendemain mais
aussi dans la carte de fin d'année tu
avais écrit et chats qui mercredi à
19h30 je vais me souvenir de toi
bonjour tout le monde au menu cette
semaine
en cassant sur la grosseur des portions
dans les restos on goûte a dégrossi de
maïs et on déguste si je peux dire des
pièces de viande un minus ttc
l'eau discussion est intéressante parce
que se contentait pas de dire j'ai le
sourire en coin mais sur ce que tu viens
l'argumentaire j'avais quand même noté
quatrième amie oui la 6e 4e avec le
souvenir y est vague c'est pas reportage
en particulier que j'ai retenu c'était
la relation qu'on avait qui étaient
comme un peu privilégié de dire tes
pensées bonnes femmes qui discutent de
ce de façon sérieuse et tout ça je me
souviens plus des discussions qu'on
avait pris ou s'il fallait que je me
batte à chaque semaine avec mon petit
frère qui veulent écouter une autre
émission ensemble c'est moi qui gagne et
je me vais quitter les petits skis pour
pouvoir en parler
ça m'a vraiment ouvert à tellement de
sujets différents pièce demande
d'aliments j'aurais peu connu autrement
gay façon des façons de concevoir
l'alimentation puis ça m'a toujours
suivi j'ai fait beaucoup d'études
différente j'ai fait un grand parcours
mais tout est toujours revenu avec
l'alimentation puis je vais maintenant
une maîtrise en sécurité alimentaire
c'est toujours avec moi j'avais une
autre vision complètement des enjeux de
la vulgarisation incroyable qui se
posent à l'émission il a tout ça ça me
vraiment j'ai un peu grandi avec les
missions que j'ai appris
de cette façon
[Musique]
c'est la photo de la classe ainsi j'ai
et voilà seul ces types et dans mon
souvenir dont petit
[Rires]
toujours
spontané et avait tellement de jarzé de
nos de l'émission jacques jeudi la
création nous avions
parlé de la bonne alimentation vous
pouvoir at on tout transmettre des
connaissances à des personnes qui en ont
besoin oui notre temps on continue nos
anciennes habitudes on continue de faire
attention où le panier bio puis en corse
m'a écouté l'épicerie absolument